el tema principal de la asamblea general
de número 53 de la oea es el
fortalecimiento de una cultura de
responsabilidad democrática con
promoción protección e igualdad de los
Derechos Humanos en las Américas Además
del fortalecimiento de la democracia en
la región se debatirá y se tratará de
aprobar el primer aumento del
presupuesto de la oea los últimos diez
años a pesar de la resistencia que ya
han expresado al respecto países como
México y Argentina de hecho los
cancilleres de México Argentina Bolivia
y Brasil no estarán presentes como si lo
estarán 24 cancilleres de la región Cuba
Nicaragua y Venezuela tampoco
participarán en esta asamblea general
que busca más financiamiento para
mitigar también los efectos del cambio
climático específicamente en
Centroamérica de hecho los países del
Caribe que son entre otros los más
afectados por el cambio climático piden
que el fondo monetario internacional y
otros organismos multilaterales de
desarrollo movilizan al menos 100 mil
millones de dólares para dar préstamos
para estos asuntos ambientales
negociación que se hace paralelamente a
la Cumbre internacional para un nuevo
pacto global de financiamiento que será
en París a partir de mañana